The idea of socialism
has become very popular
among young people.
And the reason that it's become
popular among young people
is, because they've been
told that it is moral.
Not that it works, not that
it's great, but that it's moral.
It's fair.
And we all like
things that are fair.
If we're in a room and
somebody has more money,
and somebody has less
money, wouldn't it
be more fair if we
just pooled the money--
and then we split it up
evenly among the participants?
You know, just like the
cookies in kindergarten.
Except of course, that's
not the way the world works,
and that's not actually moral.
Because in a free country,
wealth, and the capacity
to gain it, is largely
contingent on the decisions
that you make.
It doesn't just fall upon you.
Most wealth in the United
States is not inherited.
Most wealth in the
United States is
created over the
course of lifetimes,
by people who engage in
economic activity and commerce.
Capitalism is good, because
capitalism is freedom.
Socialism is bad, because
socialism is tyranny.
Not an aspect of tyranny--
socialism itself is tyranny.
The statement of socialism
is, that your labor
is owed to the society.
The notion of socialism
is, that you do not
own your own freedom.
You do not own your own time.
You do not own your own labor.
You do not own your own work.
You do not own the
products of your own work.
The basic notion
of capitalism is,
you own all of those things.
And now you have to
engage in free exchange
with someone else who
does not owe you anything.
If you want to thrive,
if you want to succeed,
you are going to have to make
something somebody else wants.
People think capitalism
is selfishness.
No, socialism is
selfishness-- the notion
that I have to
somehow supply you
the money so you can
sit in your basement
and paint with watercolors.
Socialism, the idea
that I'm supposed
to fulfill all your dreams
by paying you for something I
don't want, and
have no need for.